we lived in total Harmony and peace
literally for hundreds of years we lived
and not only we lived for hundreds of
years in peace but uh we were saved by
the Muslim Community it's a Jew and a
Muslim together and they're holding
hands just like you guys were wow that's
[Music]
amazing we lived in total Harmony and
peace literally for hundreds of years we
lived and not only we lived hundreds of
years in peace but uh we were saved by
the Muslim Community it's a Jew and a
Muslim together and they're holding
hands just like you guys were wow that's
[Music]
amazing we lived in total Harmony and
peace literally for hundreds of years we
lived and not only we lived for hundreds
of years in peace but uh we were saved
by the Muslim Community it's a Jew and a
Muslim